good morning I just want to begin by
saying it what a pleasure it is to be
here today and I just have to say that I
think Emily is amazing I threw her more
curveballs than a person should get and
she's been just incredibly wonderful and
resourceful and helpful and non reactive
what jump really appreciate that's okay
you know so I'm really grateful for that
and Seth clearly you've been very
involved as well and I just appreciate
both of your work I want to say that for
those of you who are going to follow my
slides very carefully in your hand books
that they've changed which was one of
the curve balls that I through Emily but
it does happen that you think about
things between the day you send in your
slides and the day you present and I I
did that so I apologize the findings
from mining the baby are unchanged but
they lead him is not and finally I want
to say that I like everybody else in New
England is I'm fighting off a virus that
I've had for a couple weeks so if I
start to cough don't worry i'm i'm going
to make it through my talk so i presume
all right so without further ado I just
want to start by mentioning that minding
the baby is a as I'm going to tell you
about as a mother infant intervention
that's been around for 13 years and
there's a a group of people that have
been instrumental in this presentation
and our instrumental in the work my
three co-directors Louis Sadler Nancy
close and Linda maze and Benny Finch and
Rosie Price who is a clinical team down
here in the second row trying to be
invisible worked with the mother I'm
going to talk a little bit about tanika
Simpson and Denise Webb who or the other
is the other clinical team and two
graduate students who did a lot of work
that was helpful to me in formulating
this Madeline Terry and Jessica Gork
now what the over my overview of what
I'm going to be presenting today is
there are many routes to BPD and there's
I'm sure still plenty of controversy of
what the primary routes are the
secondary routes are but I'm going to
talk about one line of work which talks
about one of the roots of BPD being the
intergenerational transmission of trauma
and I'm going to talk about it within
the context of mining the baby which is
an early intervention program we've had
very positive results that suggest that
intervening early with very traumatized
mothers can have very nice outcomes for
their babies so that their babies start
off their lives with more protective
factors with things built in for them
and in and in the mother-child
relationship that are going to make it
much more likely that they have a
different trajectory from the ones but
their mothers had you know I obviously
this is all hopeful but I do want to
tell you about mining the baby and then
I'm going to tell you about a case study
Natasha and Joey so let me start off by
talking about the work that I'm sure
many of you are familiar with which was
the work of vessel van der coke and
Judith Herman about 20-25 years ago when
they started talking about the fact that
many of the patients that they were
treating who were diagnosed with
borderline personality disorders
actually had severe significant
childhood sexual abuse physical abuse
neglect and overwhelming traumatic
relational events now one of the things
that we talked a lot about today in
infant research and I I'm I don't think
it's probably penetrated to this world
as much because we talk about infants
being exposed to toxic stress which
means overwhelming stressful events
including poverty racism food and
sufficiency etc but also familiar
trauma and I've started to think about
toxic stress the most pernicious part is
being toxic relational stress you know
early disruptions in the relationship
whether you call it attachment trauma
relational stress but it's really one of
the potential pathways to the
development of severe psychopathology
and potentially um BPD and other goons
of your personality disorders and in
fact what Judith Herman and bezel
vandercook did in the early 90s as they
said maybe a better way to talk about
some of what we're seeing is in adults
is to talk about these as post-traumatic
adaptations as something they call
developmental trauma disorder or complex
trauma disorder that is this comprises
11 group of the larger group of
individuals with BPD and the work that
they did on developmental and complex
trauma disorder has been extremely
important because what they've done what
really happened was up until the this
era people tended to think of trauma in
terms of of single event traumas that
would cause PTSD or traumas that were
you know a series of events that would
cause post-traumatic stress disorder but
what they gradually began to think about
was that in fact the kinds of traumas
that were leading to complex trauma
disorders were in fact traumas that took
place over developmental periods that is
not just at one or two points in time
but over developmental periods and in
relation to primary caregivers that is
these are disruptions that take place
and I think from a developmental
standpoint the idea that it takes place
chronically am over time and in once
primary relationships is what really
distinguishes them let's say from PTSD
and a lot of individuals with complex
trauma disorders look as if they have
depression anxiety self hatred
dissociation substance abuse
self-destructive and risk-taking
behaviors re-victimization problems with
interpersonal
intimate relations including parenting
which I you know underline emphasize
bold etc and also to have medical and
somatic concerns and despair and you'll
notice that that list which which is
unlike the list I'm also about to show
you on the next slide are not dissimilar
from what Emily put up on her slide
about the DSM criteria for borderline
personality disorder so that when you've
had the misfortune of being in a family
situation where you're chronically
exposed to trauma over the course of
development within your primary
relationships complex trauma disorder is
one possible outcome and they talk about
a series of essential post-traumatic
adaptations that ah I was going to say
where's my Kleenex i have i have a whole
drug store up here i'm sorry they talked
about a series of post-traumatic
adaptations and i want you to think
about what it would be like to be a
child if your mother is experiencing
these post-traumatic adaptations and
again these are very similar to the list
that Emily put up but alterations in the
regulation of effective impulses that is
epic dysregulation become being both
impulsive and dysregulated alterations
in attention and consciousness that is
individuals who've experienced trauma
over the course of development often are
prone to dissociation and you know sort
of out-of-body experiences and other
forms of forgetting and numbing etc
alterations and self-perception the
inability to really see yourself in any
kind of a coherent light but actually to
take on the perceptions of the
perpetrator who might have seen you as
terrible and bad and evil and worthy of
abuse and that's one of the ways that
individual complex trauma take on the
perpetrators vision of them alterations
in relationships to others which clearly
we see all the time in our mothers and
many of you have work with individuals
like this see as well somatic and
medical complaints and I'm going to come
back to this many times over which is it
mining the baby is an interdisciplinary
interdisciplinary intervention that
brings together health and mental health
work in the home from the time the
mother is pregnant and one of the things
that you see in the individuals who've
been exposed to significant trauma is
their relationships to their bodies are
very disrupted and this can manifest
itself very simply in the inability to
take care of themselves physically not
only things like nutrition and smoking
etc but more basically to take the
medications that are prescribed for them
to take the medications that are
prescribed for their children to monitor
physical symptoms and their children
that oh by the way I didn't say if you
want copies of these slides my email
will be on my last slide and you can
feel free to write and ask me for them
and thank you I see you taking notes so
so we we very much feel that addressing
the somatic side as well as the
relational side as well as the
developmental side and the attachment
side are very important and alterations
and systems of meaning which has to do
with what actually Terry I'm sorry Emily
had on her slide I'm having to do with
despair you know that is losing sight of
the larger meaning of life and larger
meaning of oneself in life now so
there's I'm going to just stop for a
minute so there's the complex trauma
literature which really focuses on the
long-term effects of trauma and then
there's been a whole other line of
research that is I think just so
fascinating and so clinically important
to everything that we do and it is
finally getting recognized but it's a
study that was started over 20 years ago
and still the adverse childhood
experiences study how many of you
familiar with it that's really
interesting
I I think I'm hoping that in five years
every hand and this audience would go up
but what they did was these two
researchers phylidia Nanda and many
colleagues interviewed created a way
they didn't do it themselves they
interviewed 17,000 middle-income adults
who were seen within the Kaiser
Permanente system in California and they
did retrospective accounts and they
developed a questionnaire asking them
about early adverse childhood
experiences and they looked at how these
early experiences predicted to medical
problems and to psychological problems
and behavioral problems later in life
and they they collected 20 years of data
and as I said it's 70 a sample of 17,000
and they found a strong graded
relationship between the number of
adverse childhood experiences the level
of traumatic stress in childhood and
health mental health and behavioral
outcomes later in life now here are the
key things that are assessed by the ACE
questionnaire whether an individual has
had recurrent physical or emotional
abuse before 18 contact sexual abuse had
an alcohol or drug abuser in the
household had an incarcerated family
member had a chronically depressed or
mentally ill family member mother
treated violently one or no parents or
physical or emotional neglect and it's a
fairly simple questionnaire that is just
administered when individuals come in
for their checkup now they've started
some various medical centers have now
started integrating this into their work
so that they pick up children who are
experiencing early adverse childhood
experiences when they're very young
within the context of their medical
visits but that's very forward thinking
so the ACE study found that health comes
health outcomes including cancer chronic
lung disease liver disease ischemic
heart disease musculoskeletal fractures
autoimmune disorder
us were strong if you had a 4 or above
on the Asus questionnaire you are more
likely to have developed these illnesses
and often too and to have pre early
death as well as substance abuse
sexually transmitted diseases smoking
and obesity and the mental health and
behavioral outcomes included depression
suicidality PTSD and the
intergenerational transmission of abuse
and teen pregnancy so that what happened
to you in childhood predicts to these
health the mental health outcomes of
course don't surprise us at all or they
didn't surprise me but the health
outcomes you know really knock me out
now there's a recent study that came out
in 2013 where they collected data from
subjects in the national comorbidity
survey replication which was again 5,500
individuals and the higher your level of
childhood adversity the greater you
number of separate DSM diagnosis the
number of different DSM disorder
categories which is consistent with that
slide I showed you before where anxiety
depression etc all are comorbid which
the complex trauma people feel is a
reflection of the fact that actually the
anxiety depression are symptoms of an
underlying disorder and that's that
underlying disorder not that needs to be
treated not necessarily CBT for
depression or anxiety but really to
address the trauma disorder and finally
childhood adversity was associated with
the presence of coexisting internalizing
and externalizing disorders so there's a
lot of reason to worry about children
experiencing adverse early experiences
now this is a slide I borrowed from a
wonderful slide presentation by the
group listed above but we call you know
there are all these different ways of
talking about adverse childhood
experience you know whether you call it
developmental trauma disorder or toxic
stress or adverse childhood experiences
it's just important to recognize that we
really have to intervene as early as
possible
to keep these from having the the
long-term effects that they can so a
major public health goal obviously is
what I've been saying is to decrease
adverse childhood experiences or toxic
relational stress because these
contribute in a direct way to later
psychopathology so I want to talk now
for a little while about the mechanisms
for the intergenerational transmission
of trauma oh sorry sure this first
I'm going to talk about a couple of
fairly simple relationships one is that
maternal trauma history leads to
disruptions in a parent's capacity to
mentalize and I'm going to talk a little
bit about what that means I know Carla
sharp will be talking about mentalizing
later this afternoon but mentalizing
refers very simply to the capacity well
the sympathy definition is the capacity
to envision mental states in the self or
the other but at a very simple level it
means when my baby is crying can I begin
to try to imagine why she might be
crying can I be curious about it can I
wonder about it can I engage in problem
solving to figure out which of my
hypotheses are correct or do I simply
try to control the crying because I want
it to stop or can I engage in the
wandering process and parents who have
difficulty engaging in that wandering
process which I'll describe in more
detail have disrupted interactions with
their children and are disabled in their
caregiving by which I mean that it's
very hard for them to protect the child
to keep the child in mind but I've been
thinking of it a lot lately as really
one of the primary functions of a parent
is to protect protect their offspring
from danger is to protect their our
offspring from harm and if your child
ceases being someone that you can really
see and really appreciate as a child and
really appreciate us having the
motivations in the developmental
capacities of an infant you're going to
be much less likely to be able to feel
like a caregiver and act like a
caregiver and of course then you get
into the whole question of how of their
own models and their own feelings about
their own parents and how unable they
may feel to take on a mothering or
fathering role and disrupted parent
parental mental ization we believe also
contributes to the disorganized
attachment and infancy and disorganized
attachment in infants
is a very problematic has it's very
highly represented in clinical samples
there's tremendous I think Public Health
value which no one has really cost it
out yet but the lower the lower the
levels of disorganized attachment the
less likely you are to see behavioral
outcomes you know really pretty quickly
and then they will show up disorganized
attachment does have a rate of
predicting various forms of severe
personality disorders and so on so we
really want to minimize disorganized
attachment and infancy so this I think I
don't need to spend a lot of time on I
think this is something that i've just
reviewed which is maternal when you have
a mother with a trauma history it's
likely that she's making a variety of
these post-traumatic adaptations she's
looking very complex diagnostically
she's having trouble regulating her
impact her FX particularly negative
effects and to contain her impulses
profound alterations in the sense of
self other and the body and then and
this is something I really want to
emphasize because it's it's really the
balance that we're after clinically
which is that individuals who've
experienced a lot of trauma are very
vulnerable to arousal that is when they
get aroused which can happen very
readily and very quickly they're
vulnerable to defenses such as fight
flight or freezing freezing being the
most pathognomonic way of responding and
that this vulnerability to arousal often
goes against the part of them that might
be able to think about what's going on
in to the other person's mind think
about what's going on in their own mind
that the we want to work on keeping the
arousal level low so that they can
continue to think about the baby to feel
the baby etc now let me talk briefly
about what parental mental ization looks
like I mean it's a very important
capacity in parents it's a curiosity as
I said and openness to the child's
thoughts and feel
but let me give you a very quick example
you know mother takes her 15 month old
and they're going to stop and pick up
some food on the way home and she's just
picked her child up from daycare he's 15
months old he's hungry he's tired they
pull into the supermarket and he starts
up why don't wanna go take me oh and you
know she has to get the shopping done
you know it's the end of the day she
doesn't really have any choice look
excuse me mother number one says you
know the magic mother that we wish we
all were and had but says oh it's okay
honey you know we're just going to have
to stop for a few minutes here you know
let me give you a hug and I'm going to
put you in the card and here's a bagel
for you to chew on those who aren't from
New York I presumably know what a bagel
is but it's a very good thing to have
when you're tired and cranky so the
mother has the child something to drink
something to eat and he can remain
regulated through this trip through the
grocery store he may want to grab
something off the shelf but what happens
in this instance is the mother
recognizes what his states are what his
needs are he needs to be talked to he
needs to be touched he needs to be
calmed down he needs to get through that
10 minutes of excruciating shopping time
and that she has a big part to play in
that adaptation and what's going to
happen at the end of that 10 minutes is
it mom's not going to be all freaked out
either she's not going to be all
dysregulated because you're not going to
have the cycle that you might see in
another situation where by the time
let's take the other situation which is
they get to the parking lot the child
starts to whine and the mom says okay
we're not going through this again you
do it every single time and I want you
to be quiet and she picks him up out of
the car you know and she's tense and she
probably you know hurts him a tiny bit
you know puts him in the cart and said
now you just cut it out and you can you
know she doesn't give him anything to
eat she doesn't soften her voice she
doesn't touch him and by the time you
you know and then he of course he
reaches for things in the store and she
says no you can't have that and i told
you when you're trying to drive me crazy
which by the time he's 15 month
oh [ __ ] could be right but the point is
that by the time they get to the
checkout they are both dysregulated
right and cheese can't think about him
and he can't think about her and the
first mother would have a reflective
stance you notice that if she's aware
that something is triggering his miss be
his misbehavior and she wants to do what
she can to contain it as opposed to a
mother who might really feel that she
needs to control him physically and it's
the hardest thing to do clinically often
is to move a parent off the dime of I
want to control him too you know okay
let me calm down a little bit let me
think about this let me wonder what's
going on with him let me see if we can
figure it out and that is a really key
shift that we work on all the time in
mining the baby but Linda Mays has done
a lot of really fascinating work on kind
of the balance between arousal and
regulation and that once you get over
aroused you can't really mental eyes
anymore so what we're trying to do
always is to regulate arousal to the
point where mothers can and it's very
difficult to do I mean this work is very
hard trauma and intense negative affect
severely challenged and may preclude
neck mental ization that is the more
distress the mother becomes the more
difficult this is and one of the things
that I think a lot about is how
triggering an infant's normal behavior
can be for a traumatized mother seeking
care wanting to climb up on her lap
crying reaching for her all things that
may have been very different in the
mother's own experience that may be very
triggering for her or simply the feeling
of being physically violated by the baby
which is a normal part of motherhood
right of being physically you know taken
over by the baby and so that the feeling
the potential for threat in the
mother-child relationship is high when
you pet high levels of trauma and the
parents can be more vulnerable to
implicit or imagined threat and their
own fear system gets regular
readily activated and this is again what
I'm talking about when you arousal and
the fight flight or freezing really gets
triggered and as I mentioned earlier one
of the function one of the things that
happens when a mother gets triggered is
she has difficulty seeing the baby is
separate from herself reading his cues
or observing his fear and one of the
things that Peter Funaki says in his
work on mental ization is that once you
see the other person's fear and
experience it and feel it it's no longer
possible to be violent toward that
person that is that an appreciation of
who's in there keeps you from being
violent but of course if the child is
triggering and threatening and no longer
this tiny baby having a bad night but
something worse then you you really get
the potential for violent behavior and
this leaves the child alone and afraid
and one of my favorite people to write a
lot about attachment trauma is John
Allen and I totally recommend his books
a llen now again I talked earlier about
a mother feeling like herself as a
mother and when you're overwhelmed by
threat you don't see yourself as a
protector and you don't see yourself as
someone who's stronger and wiser and
Bobby really talked about an attachment
figure for the child needing to see
themselves as stronger and wiser and
when you're overwhelmed it's very
difficult to feel that way now I said
earlier that disrupted parent parent
capacity to keep the child in mind or
hold the child in mind is related to
attachment now attachments and we are
all born with the capacity to become
attached we're all born ready for
relationships and in particular when
we're threatened we seek the care of our
stronger and wiser caregiver and what
happens at that moment moment is that
the caregiver where it's the mother the
father the grandmother they're carrying
system is active and they were super
Kate by protecting the child and the if
your experience as a child is that when
you
threaten and you seek care you receive
it that is going to be be stored and
contained in you in one way if when
you're threatened and you seek care
something else happens either the mother
turns away or she gets more frightened
herself or she frightens you then you're
going to have a very different
experience of what happens when you see
care and what happens is that infants
adapt to their experience of seeking
care they learn when I you know get
upset my mother shuts down and is not
there and so I better modulate my
distress if I want to maintain my
relationship with her and so the child
when the caregivers response is not
optimal is that they learn how to
contain their feelings so that they can
get what safety and security they can
and they defend against those feelings
that get in the way so secure attachment
which is kind of the gold standard what
we you know sixty-five percent seventy
percent of people in the population are
securely attached which is that you know
when you're mildly stressed I mean
threat is a normal thing in everyday
life and hopefully it's resolved quickly
it's resolved within the relationship
the mother provides safety and a secure
gate base the child feels free to
explore the world and regulate negative
act effect and it's we think of it as a
protective factor and mothers who turn
away I found these little slides on the
internet who turn away when the child
might be needy they learn pretty quickly
to keep their feelings to themselves and
I love this slide which i also found on
the internet which is a child and a tiny
little wading pool wearing a big inner
tube with more inner tubes in about
three inches of water which is that
mother is so anxious about separation
that the child learns well I guess if I
if I separate it's going to freak her
out and I better stay close and you know
she really whenever I feel frightened
she amplifies it and then what we see in
the more pernicious situations that are
what we're really
trying to avoid is that mothers who when
the child is threatened or needs them
becomes frightening as in looming and
scary which unfortunately we see a fair
amount about or becomes frightened and
withdrawn right we think of that as
potentially being dissociated so that
leaves a child in a very difficult
biological situation I am threatened I'm
over aroused and I can't get what I need
from my mother because or father because
she is at the moment scaring me and so
the child doesn't develop a systematic
way of seeking safety and remains
disoriented and confused and this is
highly represented in clinical samples
and as I said there are some links that
have been found with borderline
personality disorder in when there are
maternal histories of unresolved trauma
or Los and we've found that the more
able a mother is to mentalize the more
likely she is to be secure in relation
to attachment the more likely the child
is to be secure and the lower level the
less it's likely that the child is to be
disorganized so what we're trying to do
then is to decrease relational trauma
and maltreatment to address the mother's
own trauma history to help Mother
identify herself as a caregiver to
enhance mother's capacity to think about
the baby too and I think about the baby
is not the right word it's to marry
tarjay who's done a tremendous amount of
work in this field said it's thinking
about feeling thinking about the baby's
feelings but also feeling about thinking
meaning that effect is not left out of
this picture that but it's integrated
and coherent in within the context of a
thought that is effect doesn't become
dysregulated and disorganized increase
rates of secure attachment decreased
rates of disorganized attachment and
increase harmonious interactions wit by
decreasing maternal frightened and
frightening behavior ok so now I'm going
to talk about minding the baby
which is a mental ization based
intervention and Carla sharp is going to
be talking later about other mental
ization based interventions and we got
some of our inspiration from the work
that you all have been doing it managers
for a long time and as I said these are
this is our team which is and these are
some of our supporters and these are
many of our helpers okay so what is
mining the baby it's a service that we
it's an interdisciplinary program it's a
team that is met services are provided
by a team that is made up of a masters
prepared licensed social worker and an
advanced practice nurse so that they
have a high level of training and each
one has their own work and they have
overlapping work so that the health care
provider works on health related issues
the social worker works on mental health
and infant parent psychotherapy issues
and together they work in a variety of
ways and also on a variety of social
service needs I mean the level of
support that our moms need is really
great and together they work on
attachment and parenting they alternate
visits that is they got one goes one
week one goes to next week it's a blend
of a nurse family nurse home visiting an
infant parent psychotherapy model
they're supervised together and
separately but the idea that we had in
developing this program was that you
focus on a range of needs and try to
address a range of needs it's a
relationship based model the first
second and third thing that the home
visitors try to accomplish is to develop
a safe relationship with the mother
safety has been implicated and safety is
so important in so many treatments and
it's certainly if you read Christine
court woz work on working with complex
trauma the achievement of a safe
relationship with a practitioner is so
important and the mothers talk about how
important this is to with a predictable
concerned and caring helpful supportive
non-threatening right
we're trying to avoid the spike in
arousal the connection between the
mother and of course between a Nemet
clinicians and the child in the
clinicians that is the mother the child
has a relationship with the clinicians
after they come into the house for 27
months so there are multiple
relationships which if we thought would
be very complex for traumatized moms but
actually they do very well with this we
have high levels of trauma in the
population that we serve we do have some
fair number of complex trauma disorders
we see in them caen chronic over and
under arousal that is they either very
shut down are very dysregulated profound
disruptions in the stress regulation
system and oftentimes and this will be
true in the case that I'm going to talk
about shortly you don't necessarily hear
about the trauma in the first visit or
the second visit or the third visit or
the tenth visit or the 26th visit but it
may come out very late in the treatment
and you're really working knowing it's
there kind of working from the various
signs maybe some of those post-traumatic
adaptations that tell you it's been
there you're attending to nuances and
the mother's reaction titrating
discussions are tuning to dissociation
just being very aware of that but one of
our major emphasis is to develop or
enhance a parent's capacity for mental
ization to be able to reason about or
reflect upon the child's thoughts
feelings wishes needs etc and the
mothers capacity to do that we believe
it's very regulating for her as well as
for the baby and as I said it's based on
a lot of other work done in mental
ization theory the framework of the
model as we start in the transition to
Parenthood the transition to Parenthood
is an incredibly rich developmental
moment many I am when I was a kid I
summa freiburg wrote the most beautiful
wonderful paper on infant parent
psychotherapy working with very
traumatized mothers in nineteen the
first paper came out
76 and I started was trying to start an
infant parent program probably it was
about nineteen eighty-four 82 and I went
to meet with one of the people who had
written the book with Robert on early
infant mental health and I forget what
naive supposition I had laid on the
table as a young person um night you
know and she said you need to remember
that every mother no matter what their
childhood experience wants to do better
for their child there is not a single
parent under any circumstances and that
is what Selma freiburg called having God
on your side it's just that knowledge
that when you're working with a mother
whatever else gets in the way she does
have this desire particularly when she's
pregnant right in this rich
developmental moment where things are
changing hormonal II her body is
changing daily and there are crucial
biochemical changes going on and these
will be and these these hormonal
biological changes will be going on not
only prior to birth but immediately
after birth the opportunity for
attachment is very high at this point
and as is the opportunity for trouble
right because it's such a vulnerable
developmental period so this is a period
that we start in the second trimester of
pregnancy it says third here but
actually we try to get in in a second
you missed that one Rosie Rosie is
really good at double checking my slides
and we go weekly until the child is one
and sometimes much more often and then
every other week till the child is too
we are very flexible as I said we go
more often as needed or whatever and we
use a wide variety of curricula and
approaches so I'm going to briefly run
through this to get to our findings that
is we began 13 years ago and we've been
randomizing subjects into control and
intervention groups from conditions from
the beginning we've had 237 families
enrolled in
study 133 of these have gone through the
intervention and I'm going to talk about
our data from 105 intervention and
control families and it's a high-risk
inner-city sample with high levels of
poverty family disruption trauma
substance use in the substance use in
the immediate family none of our moms
are using actively themselves not having
drugs there's recreational drug use of
course it's a first child birth mothers
between 14 and 25 who are not involved
in major drug use or have a major
terminal illness and we collected data
at okay somebody's okay we collected
data in pregnancy four months 12 months
and at graduation at 24 months we
collected a variety of health records
behavioral interaction attachment mental
ization data etc and we had sixty
mothers in the intervention group their
average age is 19 and a half most had
completed through the 11th grade
sixty-six percent were latina the
remainder primarily black and other
mixed backgrounds a small number were
married a larger number we're cohabiting
some others had no contact with the baby
at all and interestingly in our mining
the baby group they had a high level of
social service involvement meaning that
their parents were being watched by
child protection because they had been
abused so the mothers themselves had
open DCF cases and one of the just to go
through our findings the mind the baby
group was more likely to be up to date
on their immunizations at 12 months
which is an important public health
outcome we had no open cases in the
mining the great group with respect to
protective services that is none of the
kids in the intervention group had been
reported for child maltreatment and we
we and the control group had five
percent open
which did not reach statistical
significance but it almost did so we are
we are seeing a very an impact on health
outcomes and on child protection and we
are also seeing that mothers in our
intervention group are much less likely
to have subsequent children right away
you know one of the biggest public
health important public health outcomes
is to space children at two years or
more and often in this community you
know children moms will have babies
right one after the other and we've been
pretty successful in working really
strongly around birth control to get
moms to wait until they have a second
child and that in and of itself as the
home visitors could tell you can be very
challenging when we looked at the mother
baby interaction at four months using
carlin lines ruth's ambiance measure we
found there was much less disrupted
communication among the mothers and
babies at four months particularly with
teens and what this means and I will
talk about it a little more when I get
to the case study but at four months
they've only been in the intervention
force for seven months right since the
third trimester of pregnancy and so we
were hoping that we would see changes in
the interaction as early as the baby's
being four months old and in fact we did
mothers were less likely to either be
looming and frightening with the baby or
withdrawn and in disengaged most
significantly for us we found that at 12
months there was a significantly higher
percentage of securely attached infants
in the intervention group and we have
added many subjects to this group since
running these initial analyses and we
have consistently found a higher level
of security at mandir Jill dhryn in the
intervention group and more importantly
a significantly lower percentage of
disorganized infants in the intervention
group and that has continued to hold so
we feel that we're really getting
somewhere in terms of
attachment outcomes and we found that
everyone's RF got better over time
including those in the control group in
part because the you know your baby
better as you as you get to know the
baby but in higher risk mothers that is
mothers who started with very low levels
of mental ization and pregnancy or those
who had had less schooling their RF
their mental ization I'm sorry I didn't
define RF and mental ization tends to be
used interchangeably and they don't
actually mean exactly the same thing but
we don't have the time for me to make
the fine distinction between those two
but when you what you measure in
Mother's is their reflective functioning
that is the capacity to reflect on the
baby and the higher risk mothers in our
group were much better at that than were
the mothers in the control group and
then we did a follow-up of a smaller
number of children and we found that
remember I was talking about early
adverse childhood experiences and
behavioral outcomes we found lower
levels of externalizing acting out
behavior in the mining a baby sample
versus the control group so we're hope
we hope you know that we'll continue to
see this but there are lower levels of
problematic externalizing behavior
disorders at follow-up and the mothers
in mining the baby reported less
parenting stress than did those mothers
in the control group so we were very
happy with these findings and we felt
that we were having we hope we're having
an impact on the the what do we want to
call it the interruption of the
intergenerational cycle of the
transmission of abuse so that the
adverse experience is that the mother
might have experienced are not being
repeated in the child's experience and
of course when they are we're right
there to intervene so we've had a three
site replication in the united kingdom
begun in 2011 and in collaboration with
National Center for the Prevention of
Cruelty to Children and the Anna Freud
Center and I think where our goal is to
help mothers be open and curious about
their own in the child's emotional
experience to be aware of their own in
their infants physical states and to
provide care for the child and to remain
non defensive and unthreatened and able
to regulate and contain their own and
their child's distressed and to one of
the things that is so frequently
emphasized in parenting interventions is
teaching parents parenting skills &
parenting skills I believe it i believe
it is futile to teach parents skills
without teaching them understanding that
is until they can take a reflective
stance you know I wonder why even though
I've told him that you know he can't go
to that they can't go to that electric
socket you know I understand that he
doesn't make any sense of no and yes
visa V this and why this incredibly
interesting thing isn't something he can
go and play with so I need to take his
development into account that is a
parenting skill involves developmental
understanding which you can't acquire
unless you're curious about the child
but we hope that the kind of work we do
provides a basis for developmental and
anticipatory guidance for self-efficacy
and improve life course in the mothers
and indeed we see that we spend a lot of
time establishing a relationship with
the moms we try to help the clinicians
remain reflective but it's very
important to understand that when you
work with highly traumatized individuals
you can easily become over aroused and
threatened yourself and have a variety
of very intense emotional reactions to
the work and we provide layers and
layers of supervision to managing this
and we try to help the mothers wonder
what is going on and why whether it's in
themselves or in the baby without
threatening her and triggering fight
flight or freezing and we hope to see
the gradual emergence of mentalizing
capacity
and sensitive mothering and I just this
is my favorite slide right now and the
point that I try to make with this slide
is we try and is we try to help mothers
get to a space where they can be open
and honest and they can reflect on their
experience reflect on their history
reflect on what's going on with the baby
reflect on what's going with their
partner without dipping into either a
hyper aroused dysregulated state or
shutting down and going into an under
aroused over-regulated state and the
interesting thing about this diagram is
the clinicians ten minutes whoa okay the
clinicians are as vulnerable to these
curves hopefully it's not as vulnerable
but they can be vulnerable to and
sometimes you'll see the clinicians
getting hyper aroused and the moms
getting under aroused you know it's like
they shut down because the conditions
gotten really worried because there's
violence going on and this is something
that's very important to monitor okay
these are some comments by mining the
baby mothers which the one I love best
is they give you pieces of your heart
and these are cupcakes that a formerly
homeless woman who started a cupcake
business did for us which have care love
mining the baby they're always there to
help and there's my promised email
address you can write me for the
complete slides thank you very much
so much dr. Slade we have many questions
coming in so we'll get through as many
as we can unfortunately dr. Slade is not
able to be with us for the panel at the
end so again we'll do our best with this
and there might be some questions here
that perhaps dr. Sharpe might know might
be a dancer with regard to research on
mental ization based treatments which
she lost me discussing she will she will
know that literature inside and out and
I will be around until to 15 so so
people might be on approach to want to
break what okay so little questions the
first one is these please speak to how
mental ization differs from empathy hmm
oh well that question has probably been
asked four thousand times or maybe
40,000 because it's a it's a empathy I'm
going to give you the simple answer
Carla may want to jump in and add her
piece but empathy does not involve at a
very basic level as much distance right
that is as much perspective because
empathy is a is an emotional reaction
and you can have empathy for your child
and you can still give them that soda in
line at the store right but it's that
capacity to have a some perspective to
have your cognition working if you will
at the same time that your emotional
reaction is working so that many people
equate empathy with mental ization but
in fact they're not the same because
mental ization is defined and I'm sure
dr. Sharpe will speak about this more as
a as a function of the frontal cortex
right and that's why when arousal goes
wild you know the frontal cortex is not
functioning the way that it should so
empathy i would think of is in part a
lower brain response but the mental
ization you know adds a piece to that
though thank you we have a question
about how act
the treaters are focusing on either the
trauma history of the mother or directly
on the mental ization mental ization is
something that the home visitors receive
extensive training in it's a big part of
supervision so mental ization is
something that they're trying to do all
the time from the beginning to make the
mother more aware of herself in
pregnancy to begin to make her more
aware of the baby so that it's an active
part of the relationship and oftentimes
it's the clinician who meant Eliza's
first and then we're hoping that the
mother can begin to calm down enough to
begin to use some of these same
capacities herself the treaters are only
as active as they can be with the trauma
history you know this is actually I
think an ongoing debate within the
context of infant parent work this is a
voluntary program this is something
offered to moms if they desire it as
part of their prenatal care and
oftentimes this was the case with
Natasha it took a very long time to
figure out who the father of the baby
was what had really happened between
them what had really happened with her
mother it took 18 months before she
agreed that her own mother was toxic
even though having told stories of you
know maltreatment earlier on in her work
with the home visitors so you know you
can you know it's not a trauma-focused
CBT let me put it that way that we work
with the trauma as I mean would you to
agree with that that you it comes up as
you can and but you're very attuned to
it you know and you try to bring it up
but you can't thank you there's a
question about can you can you speak to
the difference between a primary
maternal preoccupation versus borderline
personality disorder or features in
talking about the moms it's kind of are
we talking about to what extent are we
talking about borderline personality
disorder or features in the moms versus
the the trauma to various
he talked about the the problems that
the mothers have I'm afraid I don't
understand i guess i guess the question
is is is so coming back to to the
conference focus on borderline yes are
we talking about the at-risk moms are we
talking about moms who struggle with
borderline features some some yes i mean
this woman that i talked about was had
you know very strong narcissistic
features it was really reflected in her
relationship with everyone but
particularly the home visitors at cause
tremendous counter transference issues
for the home visitors we thought that
she had some impulse issues and affect
regulation problems that would call her
having borderline features and certainly
a number of the moms have complex trauma
disorders potentially borderline
problems I would say you know we don't
we don't do a skid at the beginning of
this study you know so we we just go in
our clinical instincts but I think the
thing I would say in terms of primary
Metron you asked a question about
premier maternal preoccupation that's
what threw me off a preoccupation about
the primarily on maternal preoccupation
I think the mother focused on cells
versus borderline personality disorder
or something like that I think that's I
think that's the question ok Emily DC
one thing that okay we have a question
about how can extended family members be
effective intervening if if there's a
number of warning signs the behavior of
the pairing so i think this is looking
at grandparents and other things like
that if they're have concerns about the
sort of things you're talking about what
might they do i guess the simplest
answer that comes first to my mind is a
child needs a secure base and if it's
the grandmother if it's the father if
it's an aunt if it's someone who you
know really can provide that for the
baby when I mean obviously this the
answer is to get help if it's if it's
possible oftentimes is a grandparent or
an aunt or an uncle or an extended
family member you're somewhat paralyzed
in your ability to help up to a certain
point but I do i do think of adult
patients I've worked about worked with
who have talked about the important and
Alicia Lieberman and Bill Harris have
written about this they talk about it as
angels in the nursery as people who are
critical incredibly important organizing
regulating figures for the child and so
that that's one function for example of
grandparents it's one function of
extended family members you know I think
of a someone I know who you know it's
terribly concerned about her daughter's
interaction with her child and she just
resolved to be there for the child as
much as she possibly could and that you
know somebody who loves you who's
regulating for you is very important
someone along these lines we have a
number of people asking about the
inclusion of the fathers in minding the
baby if father like that that should
shame on me for not having that more
prominently in the slides if the fathers
are around they are involved at their
home they're included in the home visits
we make special efforts to do the home
visits at times that they can attend if
they want to be grandmother's are often
big part siblings we've had a number of
siblings in minding the baby but
siblings who may be younger than the mom
will sit there and receive part of the
intervention and hopefully take it in
you know when they have babies
themselves there's a question here oh
about dumb to what extent is mine
minding the baby take into account
cultural differences in parenting me
leola relationships etc is it sufficient
to say very much you speak a little bit
too yeah I mean culture is where we're
working we're working in a very diverse
with mothers from diverse cultures in
the areas in which we work there are
families from the African American
community there are families from Puerto
Rico from Dominican Republic from South
America from the West Indies etc and
there are individuals who have you know
lived in a new
even their whole lives and their people
who are just more fairly recent
immigrants and one of the things that
our home visitors work incredibly hard
on is starting from the position of I
need to learn from you about what you
feel given your cultural you know
perspective etc works for you and your
baby but also obviously we're often
countering cultural ideas like it's let
me try to think you know for instance
about what foods are good for babies or
when food certain foods should be given
to babies or whether you should ever let
a baby cry you know all of those kinds
of things are intensely culturally
mediated and they're rarely is a right
answer that's you know got to be
adjusted to the family and so on given
the things you spoke about in terms of
child tank of services involvement that
sort of thing can you speak to how to
maintain or regain safety in connection
to the therapy relationship if the
providers have had to make mandated
reporting calls and so um well we have
had well one mother that I can speak to
when you have to make a report the place
you start is with the mother and really
helping her understand why you're having
to make this report you know what it's
going to mean I'm trying to think that
in the case we have in the case i'm
thinking of which is is really the only
case it that it's happened in the last
13 years it was the hospital that made
the report because they didn't feel that
the mother could take the baby home and
we became very involved both in working
with the social you know with child
protection working with the hospital
super helping the mother in the
supervised visits that she had with the
child being present for all the
supervised visits really and then
helping her when the baby came back home
you know because they were you reunited
so we work very huh and you know it's
going to disrupt the relationship if
you're the one having to make the call
hopefully you spend enough time working
with the mother understanding why it's
necessary to make the call and what how
you're going to support her through the
you know you don't just make the call
and go away there are a few questions
will end with these ones before before
our break and again a lot of the other
questions were more about methods which
I think we can probably bring to dr.
Sharpe there's another question about to
what extent this can be extended to
other groups to mothers who have
children of starting when the children
are older than infants higher
socioeconomic status and questions in
general about how do you refer people
how do you get into these programs well
if you're interested in mining the baby
Krista is the person to contact and we
can navigate referrals through Krista
these kinds of mental mental ization
based programs are increasingly in place
for children for adolescents i know dr.
Sharpe is going to talk about some of
the programs that they set up at many
gers I mean our focus is really on
infants but mental is a shin based
programs have been developed by people
at many gers for children you know
through the middle childhood and on to
adolescence is that sort of answer the
question didn't that into that part was
about the ages [ __ ] economic status
that you mentioned that about yeah it's
primarily about lower socioeconomic that
well I mean we've worked with
underserved very challenged families who
are vulnerable because of their
socioeconomic status I don't have any
illusion that these are unique to
families you know in low socioeconomic
groups it's much and this program I
think would be wonderful for someone in
any SES group that because as you
probably know that becomes a much more
complex issue of referrals and
acknowledgement and so on but
thank you so much dr. Slade
you